I think there's a misconception that
games are supposed to be fun that
they're supposed to be and escape now
don't get me wrong they certainly can be
but I think they're also capable of
depicting more difficult and complicated
themes the darker things that you might
play a game like Skyrim or overwatch to
escape games that deal with heavy themes
are rarely fun but they can often be
cathartic experiences with meaningful
messages a couple of years ago Danny
O'Dwyer did a video on how video games
help people living with mental illness
now in this video what I want to do is
explore how the video games themselves
are depicting mental illness and the
experience of living with it
unfortunately in videogames mental
illness is generally presented in its
most extreme and unusual forms and is
usually used to offer up entertainment
value it's generally used to enhance of
villains twisted or insane persona
service a game mechanic like the sanity
meter in horror games or portray the
vulnerability of a protagonist it rarely
mirrors the reality of what mental
illness is like for most people that
said there are games which try and deal
with the subject matter in a more
realistic way spec ops the line explores
some of the impacts of PTSD by having
you experience a brutal conflict and
watch the mental stability of your
protagonist steadily deteriorate the
platform assume shows what it's like to
deal with social anxiety by making you
move through levels swapping between the
white exposed above world replete with
monsters and eyeballs and the black
upside down in which your protagonist
can hide while there's a danger in
oversimplifying mental conditions by
making a game mechanic out of them in
some cases it works quite well
demonstrating that games can do darker
themes justice one of the reasons I
think video games can be an exceptional
medium for conveying mental illness is
how adept they are at instilling empathy
through interactive engagement actual
sunlight might be the most painful game
I've ever played but I think it's also
one of the most important it brilliantly
conveys the hopelessness apathy and
submission to dysphoria that can develop
from major depressive disorder actual
sunlight is about the very worst parts
of what is considered to be a somewhat
common mental illness your character at
in winter sometimes simply can't do what
you ask him to he refuses to take the
positive option you choose for him
whether that be a lifestyle choice or a
hopeful interaction his mental state has
pushed him to a point where he's
incapable of it and I think for some
people that's incredibly however
upsettingly relatable the game is also
full of rhetoric on dealing with
depression as well as struggles with
society and identity that pop up when
you interact with items
the world actual sunlight is an
excellent depiction of what it's like to
live with severe depression and it's
illuminating to play for those who don't
that said it is extremely disturbing in
parts and I would advise caution if
you're experiencing severe depression
yourself if actual sunlight is about
reaching the point of no return where
nothing seems salvageable then the cat
lady is about what happens after that
point you play as Susan Ashworth a
severely depressed woman whose only
companions are stray cats she decides to
end her life and ends up being granted
immortality by a woman who appears to be
the embodiment of death you then play as
Susan as she's forced to face life again
to find meaning that confront her
problems and attempts to connect with
other people you'll need to keep your
mental state in check by doing things
that make Susan feel better in real life
this is called self-care with every
trial for lack of a better word that
Susan overcomes she grows in confidence
several times referring to herself as a
tough old girl late in the game me dad
no no I'm a tough old girl like actual
sunlight the cat lady is honest in its
portrayal of a person suffering through
depression and suicidal tendencies
Susan is often morose suspicious and
apathetic in some ways the cat lady is
about beginning at the point of
helplessness and detachment and then
progressively finding a way back to
discover things worth living for
the cat lady manages to be hopeful
without being cloying or sacrificing its
genuine depiction of Susan's illness and
for that reason I think it's well worth
playing for both sufferers and non
sufferers but the game that maybe you
want to write this feature is the town
of light a psychological horror game
based around the controversial events
that unraveled at a mental asylum in the
1930s it originally launched on PC last
year and is now coming to console with
more story elements and puzzles I was
initially cautious about how it would
handle mental illness as it's built as a
horror game but fortunately that's just
a reductive description the town of
light isn't so much about the study of
an individual suffre as it is about
exploring the broken medical system of
the time and exposing the tragic and
inhumane way that mental illness was
perceived and treated in the early
1900's the protagonist Rene is suffering
from depression paranoia and delusions
the game does a good job of forcing you
into the headspace of a tortured girl in
a terrible place and it's extremely
uncomfortable and upsetting you're
confronted with flashbacks as you walk
the halls of the nail decrepit asylum
and relive the horrors of what Renee
enjoyed both in her imagination and in
reality the only real horror comes from
the gruesome history of the asylum and
experiencing in first person the
degradation of Rene's sanity and
well-being as her condition is worsened
by a cruel system incapable of treating
her it's not a modern experience of
mental illness but it is well worth
knowing about for those who are
interested and the fact that a videogame
can convey that is pretty damn cool last
but certainly not least I want to add
that if you or anyone you know is
dealing with depression or mental
illness there are places to turn and you
are not alone you can find contact
numbers for lifeline services below let
me know what heavy themes do you think
videogames handle well or what kinds of
things you'd like to see them broach
further I'd love to hear your thoughts
so please do find me on Twitter or leave
me a comment down in the comment section
I will see you again soon
[Music]
you